guys we've got a new gate in town
there's Ben Ben gate there's Ben hiss
gate there's been so many different
iPhone themed gates that I've lost track
but guess what we've got a new gate in
town guys I am excited to bring you
crack gate that's what I'm calling it so
the other day my friend ed was like hey
does your phone do this and he held it
up to my ear and just slightly went like
this and I'm hoping that I'm able to
recreate this sound so that you guys
will audibly be able to hear it on video
but I guarantee if you take your phone
out of its case and you go like this
just a very slight they're gonna hear
like a little tiny crack sound I did
this test also on my iPhone 6 and my
iPhone 6s and they do not make that
sound so what is it so we're really it's
not really a big deal at all I don't
think but I just thought it was kind of
funny so I said Edie I'm gonna take this
information that you have supplied to me
and I'm going to make a youtube video
about it and hold this really close to
the microphone and see if you can hear
it okay off the decibels
so this is the iPhone 6 doesn't make
this out iPhone 6s doesn't make the
sound how are your balls we're your
father okay yo have you just been you
barely do it you hear it I can't get my
keys like you hear what it's like you're
doing something
no I god you're messing with us no I'm
not do it you can do it yourself
I have no crap
yes you do because I did it's yours let
me take my rings off just so you know
she's doing something I'm not doing it
no I don't even hear a crash she's crazy
no one you don't do it very hard you
just go like this she's doing something
no I'm not doing anything I heard that
like I look this very easily that's
interesting yeah do you that yeah it's
your finger no it's not do it to you
guys that a big deal you're doing
something no I'm not I'm not doing
anything to hear it
no but why does it matter it matters
very much what you don't hear that I
don't think I care enough okay have fun
crazy
yeah but it it's a biggie
it's a big deal but I understand what
you hear right I never heard it get back
over here I need confirmation listen I
don't believe I think you're tricking me
to something I'm not look I'm not
tricking you
I hear it but I don't understand my
other phone doesn't do that do it just
do it on yours
I heard it oh well I guess I'll clean my
phone and be alone my merry way carrying
my son even happens with my case on it
this is really big news I'm not crazy
I'm not crazy Edie
they don't care now okay here look
listen Shh here I mean I I don't I can't
really walk over me okay
Jenna shut up I hear it do you hear it
you see I'm not doing anything with ya
okay but john mavar just like okay
what's the big deal what's the big deal
Wow well it's clicking what listen there
is it's so loud you can hear it oh my
god breaking my ears it's it's crazy
it's so loud it's like a ping-pong ball
a hundred feet away
tapping on like a driveway it wasn't
listen yep
it sounds just like that it sounds like
somebody's outside with the door closed
on her feet away in the wind dropping
like a dropping like a paperclip on a
piece of notebook paper I hear it
crack gate yeah if we're always search
from grad gate listen it's a thing
everybody take out your iPhone 7s pluses
in maybe a seven I don't know give it a
little yeah give it a little twist give
it a little turn and see if you can hear
the crack
it's a tiny crack you don't have to like
really don't like damage your phone just
you but see how much Mike no pressure at
all like Smurfs strength look I'm just
letting the wind do it really I tested
the iPhone 6 and iPhone success no crack
I mean I feel like things so beautiful
it's making sound all by itself crack 8
2016 it's like a cat purring inside
there one more part of time hey are you
just pressing the button no no I'm like
I'm pressing about my head - this is
only good it does cuz I tested his out
similar you're really giving it the
works though no I'm really touching
can we make a song while yours is louder
you can make a beat do any other phones
that Maddy sleeping Oh wake him up with
him loud but look at him he looks like a
ham roast see if you hear it buddy if he
looks like a hammer ogle ham roast a
little searches but this was probably
the one that I was most excited about
because it said that this link trademark
confirms that were getting three new
MacBooks this week no details aside from
the model numbers but the real
information is there's three new models
they're looking forward to a 13 inch 15
and fingers-crossed new MacBook Air this
is all extremely exciting because I do